foreign
[Music]
film independent for letting us do this
my name is Robert Greene and we are here
with the great Chris Smith Chris how are
you doing today very good
nice to see you
um I do want to start with acknowledging
the passing of Mike Shank from from your
uh Masterpiece American movie uh what
that just what you want to say any words
about the one of the most legendary
screen presents maybe in movie history I
think documentary fiction everything
movie history
yeah it's it's uh you know you just
don't realize time is marching on right
like in you know but it yeah I remember
it's funny a lot of people I think I had
more people reach out to me about Mike
Shanks passing than
anything I've done in my life so um so I
mean I think that's a real Testament to
how beloved he was and how many people
he touched
and and and a testament to your
filmmaking I mean American movie I I I
was of the age like I think I saw it
when I was like 23 right so like yeah
perfect age to be massively influenced
by that film and it's great to see your
work continue obviously you've done so
much else but I love to think about this
love senior in relation to American
movie because in some ways they're both
about filmmaking they're both about the
dreams the imagination of filmmaking
um so the maybe a couple callbacks but I
just want to definitely I wanted to
acknowledge Mike and um yeah for sure
it's amazing how much he meant to all of
us which is a strange thing but it's
very powerful and true
yeah
yeah well so so yeah so it's an honor to
be here with you um tell me tell me just
let's just start with how how this film
came to be like how how did you end up
making this with senior with Junior with
with uh um the family
I I actually
um I had a meeting at uh Robert Downey
Jr's company and in talking to them kind
of throughout the idea
of potentially doing a documentary on
Robert Downey Jr and it was I think a
couple weeks later I got um word back
that Robert had absolutely no interest
in doing a documentary on himself but he
did think that somebody should start
filming his father he thought it would
be a good subject and that kind of
started the process you know I didn't
really know
um what it was what it would be
um but it was you know it just seemed
like a good opportunity and the more you
know I had known Putney Swope I think as
many people did that you know anyone
that went to film school had probably
seen it but um but you know I I wasn't
as familiar with his other work and so
it was sort of like as that World opened
up it just you saw this opportunity you
know and it was this you know we
couldn't have hit started at a better
time you know like he was so full of
life and um it was it was the beginning
was really you know really exciting
yeah my relationship with uh seniors
work was I I worked at Kim's video and
my good friend Chuck Williams was
obsessed like you know he just was
totally obsessed with with Donna he
ended up actually doing a thing that
thing you might have seen for the
Criterion channel that brief documentary
about uh senior and like yeah and he and
he just I just threw me in deep into
this world of of Robert Downey Senior
and it's like it's such a completely
unique Vision I mean well so what was it
like then to be like okay I'm making a
film about this guy now I get to explore
this insane body of work what what did
that feel like for you I was really
intimidated to meet him because when you
look at the work you assume that the
person is going to be like a really
acerbic sort of judgmental uh I don't
know like it it definitely like always
gave me the feeling that
uh I don't know that there would be a
much um uh
I don't know tougher character there and
when we went to meet him he was like the
exact opposite you know like he was so
uh innocent in a way and sort of just
like playful and like uh Curious and I
you know and so to me that was like that
was probably the biggest like
uh shock and just in terms of meeting
him and sort of starting the process
yeah I mean he's he he comes off
intimidating in the film itself you know
you can imagine how intimidating he was
in real life but that's yeah the
Curiosity and the playfulness is there
what was what was his what were his
thoughts I love the part where it's like
we're not going to call it senior are
you and it cuts to the title I mean just
like you embodied the playfulness and of
the relationship it seems between senior
Junior and you as a filmmaker in the
edit of the film but what what was
seniors uh relationship with documentary
filmmaking he obviously had made some
documentary films but when you're like
we're gonna make a documentary about you
what what did he bring to that what were
his preconceived ideas about that
I don't think that he looked at it as a
documentary about himself I think he
just looked at it oh Robert's going to
send these guys over with a camera
that means I got guys with cameras
that's good and I think that's as far as
he went I think for him it was like
this isn't going to go the way they
think it's going to go is what I think
he really thought and and for him it was
just an opportunity to be back in the
game you know and be back making
something and so for him I I don't think
it was I think he probably felt like
okay these guys think they know what
they're doing but I'm gonna do exactly
what I want and I'm gonna and you know I
I think it might have um
you know maybe it would have uh
become contentious or or something or
other but like he very quickly sort of
just decamped and started doing his own
thing and at that point it sort of left
us alone to sort of keep working on you
know on the other version of the
documentary
I I love I mean it's one of my favorite
things about the film is this the idea
of the senior cut where it cuts to where
he's editing he's going through it it
it's it's you know there's all this
discussion these days about like you
know collaborating with with
participants in films and and but it's
you're taking it a whole other level
which by the way I feel like is a
throwback to American movie in a way and
and other in your other work like the
you know there's other versions of this
throughout your work where you're
essentially giving the screen up to your
collaborator which is the participant
you there are times in the film where we
see the senior cut play out
um and which reminds me of when coven
takes over the screen
it's a powerful and and and the steps
towards the when coven took over so talk
about the senior cut where where did
that come from it sounds like it came
from him just being like this is me this
is my project now kind of well yeah he
very much was like I think
what do you think I think this could be
easier for me to do this on my own over
here and so thankfully we had um Kevin
who was you know one of our you know
main collaborators Kevin and I were
shooting the film Kevin kind of took
over the senior portion of the film so
you see Kevin in a lot of the footage
and he's cutting with senior endlessly
and tirelessly and it was um you know he
really did incredible work there and it
was just such to me a gift to think of
the opportunity at this stage in life to
be able to I don't know to just have
that a project like that that you can
focus on and sort of keep moving through
I I can't imagine as a filmmaker any
anything better in turn in terms of
uh
coexisting with the reality of the
things that we're unfolding
yeah I mean you see the sparkle in his
eye when he's editing I mean it's really
it's really which which brings me to you
know the I don't want to overstate this
but
it's a therapeutic project in a lot of
ways I mean and and obviously it becomes
about the end of seniors life but I
think Junior has this great quote you
know at some point in the film where he
says you know when things happen we turn
on the camera and so you were kind of
stepping into that how did you how did
you you know you knew I mean you know as
a documentary filmmaker obviously that
your camera can activate all kinds of
things for the people being filmed it
can it can make people it can help them
it could it could sometimes cause even
harm it could be in the wrong place at
the wrong time the exact right place at
the exact right time and you know all
this right but like how did you're
stepping into a situation where Junior
says that very powerful thing which is
when we're dealing with something we
turn on the camera how did that affect
your filmmaking
the very first day that
I filmed with Junior and senior in the
Hamptons Junior came out and and Robert
said the first thing he said is there's
nothing off limits and then he just kind
of turned around and walked away while
we were setting up we barely knew him at
the time you know the one thing that he
did which was really brilliant was um
right I think it was a day or two before
we were supposed to to go we got a
message that we couldn't bring any crew
which was like really
I hadn't like picked up a camera in over
10 years and so it was like a really new
experience for me like to pick up I
don't know last time I shot was like
cameras had tapes in them you know so
like you know like it was uh or recorded
yeah whatever but it was so that that
was that I think there was something so
nice about that because it like
literally just brought me back to
American movie in a way like it just
really felt like oh wow it was like me
and one other person and we're just like
walking around and like making this
thing and it there was something that
you know even though our crews are
always small and you try to protect like
the intimacy I felt like that that just
took it up one more level where there
was no there wasn't any of the
production feeling around it it was
really just sort of it's like hanging
out with these two guys in terms of them
you know in terms of them being involved
on cameras like they both grew up on
camera you know and they grew up with
cameras so there was like I never felt
like well we're pulling out a camera
like change I never felt like even the a
blink of an eye or like anything that
changed because I think it was just so
normal you know
so that that you cut you described that
as brilliant but that must have been
stressful to be like oh by the way
whatever your plans were throw them out
yeah it was a
project you looked at you're like how
houses are we going to use you know
Alexis like higher end cameras so we're
gonna use sort of like like smaller
cameras that
maybe like have a different aesthetic
quality and and I think that like by
going a little more DIY with it I think
that it it
you know you don't know when you go into
something like this you don't know what
the expectation is you don't know if
it's as a celebrity I didn't know Robert
at all so I don't know if like you know
I I knowing him now it's very obvious
that this is the way that it would
unfold but going into it it's like I
don't know does he want
um you know the best camera you know
like you know some people do we have
like you know the highest quality
Equipment you know and and it was
exactly the opposite with him you know
which I which
um
but it was it was so it was
life-changing for me only in the sense
that I was actually it was the what I
needed to like get to be put in a
position where I could start shooting
again and since then I've started
shooting on a lot of the projects that
I'm doing and it's like it's so
liberating and so it's like you know
between Robert sort of starting that
process and then seniors influence
has like had a has forever impacted the
way that I think about filmmaking
because he always was trying to embrace
the looseness you know the um
I guess the chaos I would say of just
like not being so rigid in the way that
you approach filmmaking you know yeah
and that it really embodies the spirit
of senior right like the black and white
is obviously a choice it it the the film
feels like a throwback in a lot of ways
because we're allowed to just spend time
you know in some of these scenes play
out and you really get a sense of of
yeah that playfulness the looseness the
that the DIY aesthetic and all of it
really is senior right it's a it's a way
that the form is embodying a sort of
portraiture right like you're you've
come up with a form that speaks more
spiritually to what he did what kind of
filmmaking he he was known for
yeah he was like you know he was really
against like sit-down interviews I mean
I know we have a master interview with
Robert and things like that but like he
was definitely like you you see it right
in the first shot where he's sitting on
the couch he's like great shot nobody's
sitting good movement you know like and
but in a way it was like it was really
exciting because you had somebody that
was always challenging you and I think
that's why we you know we're like oh
well I've never shot documentary in
black and white and so when Kevin and I
like tried it after the first day of
shooting we're like yeah that makes so
much sense and it felt so nice cutting
being in seniors World especially when
you look at the early films it's all
this like black and white and it felt
like oh wow this takes you into that
space and then when he jumps to color
later it feels even more like impactful
because you're like oh wow this is like
it jumps off the screen so there are a
lot of things like that that I think you
know you'd hope that you would have come
to them on your own but I think they
were really inspired by
spending time with him and sort of
trying to absorb the lessons of
creativity that he was trying to sort of
share
yeah and and it and it honors him like
it's it it there's a there is a respect
that it it conveys which I think is
really crucial to the emotional sort of
uh uh sort of Integrity of the film
um speaking of that there's that there's
you know I I lost my dad re you know
fairly recently and um uh just watching
this film I was really struck by the
scene where junior is in therapy and
just just because of that the
just the universality of that right just
and and his ability his willingness to
share that kind of vulnerability because
in some ways it really it connects with
that other comment about when things
happen the film you know we turn the
camera on and then and then there there
are moments where he he's sort of
calling out his dad and a little bit
like suddenly gently and lovingly
knowing that it's you know you're only
going to get so far maybe with senior
right but like but there's it's
important for him to say a couple things
so I mean the therapy aspect of seeing I
mean first of all how how was that his
idea to film that was that you have no
idea Kevin and I Kevin shot that scene
and we kind of had a theory of just like
always be rolling always be shooting and
my understanding when that was actually
happening was just that you know that it
wasn't like oh let's do the therapy
scene at all it was like Robert was
doing therapy and Kevin kind of snuck in
and was able to sort of capture it and
so it wasn't really we know like many of
the not many of the things but but that
in particular when Robert's with his dad
at the end like Kevin left a camera like
there was no one in the room at that
point you know and so Kevin left an
iPhone in the corner that is the only
reason we have the two shot of both of
them and you know so Robert was
definitely not like you know all right
let's make sure we get this covered he
wasn't really thinking in those terms
but he was open and not obstructionist
to anything you know but I think he was
definitely not thinking in that moment
know so much about the film as much as
about you know
life that was happening you know
it's good to see him in therapy I'm not
going to ask you to be a psych armchair
psychologist here but you were with them
was there some aspect do you think he
had there was some aspect of this film
being about forgiveness yeah yeah well I
think it was a lot of things you know I
think he talks about it but um you know
I don't ever want to speak for someone
else so I I I I hope
there's some interview where he answers
that question but it definitely felt
like it was um
it was a way to to to to to process you
know and and
you know and Senior was excited you know
he was you see right in the beginnings I
definitely think this should be part of
the film and you know the the the there
definitely felt like
a full understanding that this was all
part of it you know and that that's what
makes movies great is I think when you
can Embrace in an honest way the good
and the bad and I think that you know to
me
I'm still you know regard take away the
fact that it's Robert Downey Jr or
senior just the fact that they were open
to allowing
cameras to document this process to me
is this still so remarkable in terms of
you know I don't I don't know a lot of
people that would want to want to do
that you know well my I mean the theory
my theory as a viewer which is you know
a lot of times well that's what you're
doing as a viewer is you're coming up
with the theory of why you're watching
this film and in some ways
um was is that they they just knew that
this was gonna be what they needed to do
you know and I think so yeah and and and
that's what I really liked about the
film was that there's uh I guess I think
that documentaries are often about
processing uh and we and we don't really
you know we're trying to tell stories
we're trying to do these other things
with the films but the reason why we're
motivated to make them and maybe the
reason why people are motivated to say
yes to being in them is because there
need there needs to be some processing
and you allow that I mean the a lot of
the edit and a lot I mean obviously the
presence of the camera but even in the
way that the film plays out it feels
like there is acknowledgment and not a
heavy-handed one at all but it's just a
gentle acknowledgment that that both
people in the you know both main
characters need to need to process the
process what what you know what had
happened to them what what's going on
the passing of Life getting through a
pandemic all of it yeah I mean I think
the important thing to realize though is
that it wasn't like senior got a
diagnosis and we're like let's document
this process it was we were making an
entirely different movie we were making
a movie about Robert Downey Senior and
then these things transpired so it
wasn't like we went into it thinking
that you know I don't think that had we
not started with senior I I do not think
that this there would have been a movie
that all of a sudden kicked into gear to
document the end of his life like I
don't think that I I I at least from my
point of view I I don't see that as you
know that that would have happened I
think it really was just
I mean when we started it was like he
was so full of life we went out to lunch
we walked you know to a restaurant and
like you know it's just it's crazy when
you think of just like the timing of it
all you know because it was literally
like the last window
that we had with him mobile and out
there and in the world and and and to me
I I felt so lucky that to be a part of
it only in the sense that I felt like we
just captured the smallest bit of of
that life force that he had you know and
and and but but I think we just
hopefully got enough that people can
feel like they got to know this person
because you know what was captured was
great and what but what's great about
seniors like every just like being in
his presence was very uh was fun was fun
you know it was like he was a funny
character I remember we were um driving
back from Rockaway and nobody was
talking for a while and uh we're like I
don't know where we were but out of
nowhere he just was like Brooklyn no
thanks and like it was like such a funny
like line and I was like oh great we
weren't rolling but you know it was like
things like that happened all the time
absolutely perfect I that scene you
described like you you set up the camera
in the fight the final scene with with
him in in bed and I I was really moved
by it
um from my personal experience of just
just the honesty of he's kind of he
still has that spark even in the last
moments but he's there's there's some
incoherence right it's it's not like he
it's not sentimental at all because it's
there's some there's a lot of you lean
you allow us to see what it really feels
like in those final moments and that
that sort of gentle so obviously you
talked about the camera and that makes a
lot of sense that there was no one else
in the room except for junior his son
and Senior but talk about the editing of
that scene because what you leave in is
so profound and and and really with such
a light touch as well yeah I mean we
worked with great editors Kevin
board was was who who was shooting and
producing and editing with senior and
doing basically everything
um Amanda Griffin
um and in the last year we worked with
um Dan Kohler who I've worked with on a
number of projects who's I think one of
the greatest Minds in editing and it was
a combination everybody pitched in but
um you know Dan was like really
instrumental in sort of
um
you know uh in in sort of helping shape
the overall structure I think one of the
things that was challenging about this
is that we started with a lens of like a
movie that was looking at seniors body
work
and I think we kind of hung on to that
for a long time even though the movie
had changed into a story about a family
about a father and son about art about
meditation on life
and and you know at some point we we
realized that the movies
um
sort of almost were mirrors to different
parts of his life right and so we could
we could we could look at
um whether it was uh Greece's Palace was
about the family and two tons was about
was about was about drug addiction at
the end you know it really
those scenes
I mean it was it was it was sad because
you know Junior
Robert really wanted to go confront his
father and have this like dialogue and
then covet hit and we were supposed to
film that and and that is sort of the
impetus for these Zoom conversations
that had but I don't think that like
that real conversation was really was
going to be had until he got there in
person and by the time he got there it
sort of was just
yeah well to me it was almost like
it felt so
like it made so much sense of course
that's how it would end up you know by
the time you get there and you set up
the camera and you have this moment it's
not possible and that there's something
about that that like says so much more
than that if the conversation never had
happened in in the first place and like
so there were things like that that were
but there was so much in that in that
scene I remember
um
like just
just piecing together like the Charlie
Parkinson's thing like the fact that he
had put in this movie that line and that
it like all of a sudden he like just out
of nowhere sort of drifts off and you
think he's like disconnected and then he
like picks up a hairbrush and says that
line there were there were things in
there that were
I guess in the best of possible ways I
remember the American end of American
movie
for anyone that remembers Mark's uncle
was sitting on the porch and has this
like Soliloquy that
was like sounded kind of like abstract
but also
you could apply it to the real world and
it was like kind of profound I felt like
that that whole interaction with seeing
it with Junior and senior in the bedroom
had that same quality where it wasn't
literal but it was like figurative in a
way that it was
it's my favorite sort of things where it
just sort of it says so much without
having to say anything at all you know
about the human experience and life and
tragedy and you know but they're still
together like there's this was so much
to it you know that like and and I think
that like I've always tried to
play things more subtle than explicit
and allow the audience to sort of
formulate their own opinions
um and so for us it was really just
trying to craft something that felt true
true to the experience in in sensitive
to the to the moment that we were let in
on you know
it's really it really exactly what you
describe is the experience you get the
sense of uh
almost like not desperate energy but
some some energy with those Zoom calls
that is very palpable I think to
everyone all of us that went through the
pandemic might like I said my dad died
during the pandemic too like not because
of it but during so it's almost you you
really did and and I we're so close to
it it's hard to say this without it
being like a smaller thing it's a huge
thing you made a great film about that
about the the subtle tragedies of the
pandemic really like those those
day-to-day things that scene where is
like people are here for a party you
know and they're zooming and it's like
it it really lands so every I think
everything you tried to do with that
really really does work and it and it's
incredibly moving let's let's end with
this just just um what do you what do
you think senior you know having made
this film what do you think senior's
Legacy is
oh I mean
I mean it's his body at work you know
like I mean
it's it's a great thing to leave behind
because you can you know what's funny is
like
we talk often that like and and Robert
says it in the movie
you know that like you don't like to be
explicit he says to his dad you know you
don't like to be explicit about the
meaning of anything you like to leave
that up to the audience which I I agree
with but it was funny right near the end
of the film we had always ended with
Robert in this hammock and and that
always felt right to us and and near a
couple months before we finished Susan
Downey just out of nowhere sent me
this YouTube clip of the Bingo gas
station Motel cheeseburger scene from
greasers palace with no context it was
just like a link and I watched it again
I was like oh my God it's like it's
there that's it that's like you know he
did he did tell us what it was all about
and how to behave and what we should do
and like you know and so like for us it
was it felt really nice to be able to
put that at the end because it um it
felt um it gave him that voice at the
end and and I felt like that scene feels
so perfect as an encapsulation of him
because it is maybe not the early senior
you know when he's on but like where the
senior that I met who you know just like
you know talking about community and
just like look after each other be nice
to each other you know and it was you
know it's the simplest of message yet it
like it it's sort of kind of all we need
to know you know
and now every time I enter Brooklyn I
could say Brooklyn no thanks yeah
exactly
and
um I'm really you know uh just thrilled
to be able to talk to you about it
because it it meant a lot to me and uh
thank you thank you
[Music]